[Música]
Fuentes cercanas a la casa blanca
confirman que el presidente ucraniano
volodímir zelensky se reunirá
presencialmente el miércoles con Joe
biden en Washington sin motivos de
seguridad no lo evitan será el primer
viaje de zelenski fuera de Ucrania desde
el inicio de la guerra ampliamos desde
Washington
el congreso peruano aprobó un proyecto
de adelanto electoral Para abril de 2024
además el nuevo gobierno de Dina
boluarte le dio al embajador de México
en el país 72 horas para abandonar Perú
luego de declarar lo persona no grata
una determinación tildada de
injustificada por los mexicanos
ampliamos desde la capital peruana
fue imposible para la selección
argentina completar su caravana por
Buenos Aires para celebrar la victoria
en Qatar ante las masivas aglomeraciones
de fanáticos que acabaron sobrevolando
la capital Messi voló más tarde hacia su
Rosario natal mientras en horas de la
noche Se registraron disturbios en torno
al obelisco de Buenos Aires
Bienvenidos a este nuevo informativo
dedicado a las principales noticias del
continente americano Mi nombre es
Rodrigo sedano y es un gusto
acompañarles abrimos el informativo con
la noticia que adelantaban medios
estadounidenses sí confirman Fuentes
cercanas a la casa blanca bolodin ir
selenski Llegará el miércoles a
Washington para reunirse con el
presidente Joe biden sin motivos de
seguridad no lo evitan además de hablar
ante el congreso en un momento en que el
gobierno de Estados Unidos planea un
nuevo paquete de ayuda militar a Ucrania
que incluirían misiles Patriot
anteriormente nuestro corresponsal en
Washington Cristóbal Vázquez nos
ampliaba los detalles sobre la agenda
que tendrá bolodimir zelensky en la
capital estadounidense
sí pasará pocas horas excelente aquí en
la capital estadounidense ahora de la
tarde se reunirá con Joe biden se
reuniría la casa blanca sería una
reunión bilateral de varias horas no
solamente con el con el presidente sino
también con el equipo de seguridad
nacional y también con el gabinete
después de esta reunión ofrecería
declaraciones a los medios de
comunicación antes de dar el esperado
discurso que tendrá en el congreso en
plenaria del Congreso
a las horas de la noche donde pues eh
trabajará para pues aprobar este
presupuesto militar del 2023 pero lo que
se espera mañana después de esta reunión
precisamente con Joe biden es que
Estados Unidos pues haga un anuncio un
anuncio de dos mil millones de dólares
más de ayuda sobre todo en un programa
de defensa de los misiles
estos misiles pues serán enviados a
Ucrania Pero antes de eso habría un
entrenamiento a militares ucranianos que
vendrían a Estados Unidos para saber
cómo usar estos misiles de defensa para
la infraestructura ucraniana que está
siendo atacada por fuerzas rusas
seguimos con más noticias de Estados
Unidos un comité del Congreso decidió
publicar un informe sobre las
declaraciones de impuestos del
expresidente Donald Trump el comité de
medios y arbitrios de la cámara de
representantes estadounidense con
mayoría demócrata decidió publicar los
documentos que abarcan seis años
especialmente el periodo en que Trump
estuvo al frente de la casa blanca entre
dichos documentos se encontrarán las
declaraciones de impuestos del ex
mandatario quien llegó incluso a
recurrir a la Corte Suprema a la que
pidió intervenir para que sus
declaraciones Fiscales se mantuvieran en
secreto la bancada republicana reaccionó
asegurando que la decisión del comité
sienta un peligroso precedente lo
escuchamos
permítanme ser claro nuestra
preocupación no es si el presidente
debería haber hecho pública su
declaraciones de impuestos como es
tradicional ni por la precisión de sus
declaraciones de impuestos Eso lo debe
determinar el servicio de impuestos
internos y el contribuyente nuestra
preocupación es que si se toma esta
acción del comité sentará un precedente
terrible que desata una nueva arma
política peligrosa que va mucho más allá
del expresidente y anula décadas de
protecciones de privacidad para los
estadounidenses promedio que han
existido desde las reformas de watergate
en más noticias sobre el país
norteamericano el portavoz del Consejo
de Seguridad Nacional de la Casa Blanca
John Kirby anunció que la administración
biden no ve que se pueda llegar a un
nuevo acuerdo nuclear con Irán en el
corto plazo Kirby acusó a Irán de haber
matado la oportunidad de cerrar un nuevo
acuerdo luego que el expresidente Donald
Trump se retirara del anterior trato de
manera unilateral en el año 2018
y elon musk sigue dando noticias tras
haberse convertido en el dueño único de
la red social Twitter Este martes
anunció que dejará su puesto de director
ejecutivo una vez encuentre a alguien
que lo reemplace esto después de que
días atrás lanzará una encuesta en su
perfil de Twitter y el 57% de los votos
fueran a favor de que abandonara el
puesto una vez que lo haga pasaría
encargarse de dirigir los equipos de
software y de gestión de servidores
renunciaré como ceo Tan pronto como
encuentre a alguien lo suficientemente
tonto como para aceptar el puesto
después de eso solo dirigiré los equipos
de software y servidores
vamos ahora hasta el Sur del continente
hasta Perú El Congreso aprobó allí un
proyecto de adelanto electoral Para
abril de 2024 una de las principales
peticiones de los manifestantes tras la
destitución de Pedro Castillo además el
nuevo gobierno de Dina boluarte le dio
al embajador de México en el país 72
horas para abandonar Perú por lo que
considera una injerencia política en los
asuntos internos luego que Andrés Manuel
López Obrador confirmara que se le dio
asilo político a la familia del
expresidente el presidente mexicano
precisamente había pedido también el
lunes elecciones anticipadas en Perú
para detener la confrontación social su
canciller Marcelo ebrard afirmó en
Twitter que considera la decisión de
Perú como injustificada y reprobable
nuestro con San Francisco Zacarías nos
explicaba las razones concretas que
esgrimió Perú para instalar al embajador
mexicano abandonar el país y qué les
espera ahora a la mujer y a los hijos de
Pedro Castillo
bueno para la cancillería peruana las
declaraciones del presidente mexicano
Andrés Manuel López Obrador resultan
graves y constituyen una inaceptable
injerencia en asuntos internos de este
país el Ministerio de relaciones
exteriores de Perú también señala que
esto representa una violación al
principio de lo que se denomina en
términos diplomáticos la no intervención
es un principio que tiene que guardar
todos los estados y por eso el embajador
mexicano fue declarado persona no grata
justamente el gobierno Azteca ha dado
instrucciones al embajador Pablo Monroy
para que retorne inmediatamente ese país
porque señalan que debe guardar su
seguridad y su integridad y también esta
tarde el gobierno peruano le otorgó el
salvoconducto a la primera dama Lilia
paredes para que ella y sus hijos puedan
seguir el asilo diplomático que les ha
otorgado México se espera que en horas
un avión mexicano recoja a Lilia paredes
y la lleve con destino a tierras
mexicanas y cerramos este Informativo en
Argentina en donde tuvo que ser
finalmente cancelada la Caravana que iba
a llevar a los jugadores de la selección
de fútbol hasta el obelisco de Buenos
Aires para celebrar allí la victoria en
la Copa del Mundo de Qatar los millones
de personas que abarrotaron las calles y
la imprudencia de algunos aficionados
como los dos que se lanzaron desde un
puente al autobús de los jugadores lo
imposibilitaron por lo que los campeones
acabaron sobrevolando la capital en
helicóptero una capital en la que se
registraron además disturbios al caer la
noche entre tanto Lionel Messi llegó en
su Jet privado a su ciudad natal a
Rosario junto al también rosarino Ángel
Di María junto a ellos viajó además
Paulo dybala quien Posteriormente se
trasladó hasta la provincia de Córdoba
esto decían algunos de los fanáticos de
la
este totalmente emocionada aunque sea
sentí que pudimos estar cerca estuvieron
arriba nuestro una locura una locura
hasta la lágrima y bueno es una alegría
grande
es esto es Argentina Papá frustrada yo
Quería verlos pero bueno no se pudo
te da bronca Estaría bueno que hagan
algo
para que se junte toda la gente los
podamos ver
el sábado renunciar mi trabajo en el
changomás que mi familia mi casa es que
es mi novia me vine acá
con las palabras de los argentinos en la
celebración por la victoria en el
mundial de fútbol cerramos este
informativo desde aquí les invitamos a
que sigan conectados a France 24 y a
France 24.com
[Música]